when i do kids like kids tell your
parents you want to be a freestyle
rapper
i'd love to build up like a mickey mouse
club of
freestyle rappers that's a nightmare
happy easter and welcome to she doesn't
read the news
with me chris turner and me alice win
alice win we can start off with
the best news of all have you heard the
good news that jesus has come back from
the dead the tomb is empty alice
he is risen it has been trending on
twitter is that right yeah
trending on twitter was the tomb is
empty now is that a sincere twitter
quote from the bible sure because like
people know lots of
republican senators were tweeting it
kevin mccarthy i mean he's leader of the
house full ex-leader of the house but um
yeah they the tomb the tomb is empty
which i never even thought of as a
appraiser right but you know something
that is weird and you've talked about
this with my mother
is that given that america is like so
much more outwardly religious
than say britain they seem much less
interested in easter than we are in
britain so i think
a year ago or two years ago i did a rap
about shrove tuesday
sorry the cat is being very inquisitive
yeah investigative i did a rap about
shrove tuesday and i was shocked that
that was even brought up because i
didn't think that americans
my brother thought we made up shrove
tuesday he did
yes we explained so show of tuesday for
those who don't know is pancake day
or mardi gras fat chews days what that
is the last day before lent right and in
lent you're supposed to give up all nice
things
for 40 days just like fish and that's to
commemorate jesus being in the desert
for 40 days and he was tested by
by satan and um so mardi gras was
followed by ash wednesday
and where you burn palm crosses and rub
the ash on your head
you you they put i don't know what they
burn actually no i think i think they
burn the palm crosses
no because that's palm sunday okay maybe
it's the ash from the
amazing meal you had the night before
sure but anyway uh
so yeah i don't know a lot of americans
that i speak to like don't really
understand what margaret is
which is weird because as a country it
is a much more religious country
so yeah it didn't feel like anyone was
like
noticing that it was easter except on
twitter i guess it's a good holiday
you get a bunny it's more important than
christmas actually really
because he comes back tonight because
the thing is if there wasn't easter
jesus just a dude do you see what i mean
he was just a guy right crazy because of
easter
yeah that's quite a good point they
should have spaced them out they should
have made easter in june why couldn't
they crucify him in june no it's spring
it's new life
i know but then it would be if you've
got two big holidays i think they're
fairly spaced out
fair enough what's what's the kind of
june holiday that we get then yeah we
don't really well you don't need a
holiday in the summer because it's the
summer that's true
i just i like that the you know
christmas
an old man brings you presents easter
it's a bunny rabbit well it isn't always
so like in france it's the bells
i beg your pardon in front this is a
shock one yeah did you not know this
so in france um all the bells of the
church just stopped ringing for 40 days
during lent because they go to rome
and then in rome the belt what do people
take them on like
carts no the bells just go to rome and
then when they come back
they bring children chocolate sorry
wait are you talking about france the
first world nation france the
the country is it so much more
unreasonable than a magical rabbit a
rabbit has locomotive abilities a rabbit
cannot
rabbit so interested in chocolate
chicken eggs well that's what he thinks
but
no i don't care about that why can't it
doesn't do you know about the tooth
mouse
i beg your pardon this is clearly a your
family thing
it is not it's a french thing um in
france they don't have the tooth fairy
they have the tooth mouse
and let me guess what does he he leaves
she uh
i actually don't remember the gender of
the tooth mouse now i think about it i
think that's the most important thing it
doesn't matter it's a mouth that
collects
teeth it's the other tooth mouse comes
and takes her teeth
i can't believe you didn't know this no
no one knows this no one listening apart
from french people who don't listen
because they lack a sense of humor
which is weird considering they believe
in tooth mice
the french haven't won the french the
best comedies in fact well that's
a debatable in a debate we're not going
to have um i'm just shocked and blown
away wow what a revelation i mean we
can't top it from there
right so in other news uh you got a vr
headset
all right bringing up my purchases so
what just cause i want to escape the
world it's not a nice place at the
moment if you've noticed this
headset was actually fairly cheap for
how good it is yeah
we're not going to advertise it because
they're not paying us any money but
although if they want to they are
so welcome if they do want to do that um
yeah we've got an oculus quest
too and it it's pretty great i i've
never got vr before because it
you had to get a headset with a gaming
pc and that cost loads of money
and the games didn't seem fun enough but
then this quest was
300 i was like that seems like a fair
balance and it is kind of amazing
it is kind of amazing um i i did the
they have this very glitchy like free
roller coaster game and it wasn't very
good but
despite not being very good it's still
good enough
that i could i could just feel my brain
being like what's going on here right
and and like my
the roller coaster would be like heading
up for a big fall
and i could like feel my brain like
juddering
into these like okay all right you
should freak out now
where's your lap bar you haven't got the
laptop oh should you not freak out
yeah and i was just my brother keeps
reminding me that it's like how in like
the 1890s
they um they used to play they played
this
very early video of
um a train coming at the screen what a
sweet cat
i know this is a comrade gorbachev i
don't think people have met him before
listeners imagine a very small faction
cat
that is comrade gorbachev he's here he's
a good boy
so um everyone freaked out when they saw
this training video right the train was
coming straight at the camera and people
would like
faint people would scream they'd never
seen moving pictures like sure
but what's interesting to me is that
like that's no longer how people feel
when they see a video unless you go to
like shrek 4d
at universal and then you're like oh my
god he's farting in my face i guess but
what i'm
saying is that this virtual reality
stuff may not continue to have this this
effect on us
like maybe in 20 years it just won't
seem as magical
perhaps however i was playing super hot
vr which is a kind of
time freeze shooty game and there's a
bit where you're in a room and there's
just a knock at the door and because the
3d audio the way you're facing it comes
from just over your shoulder so i
genuinely thought someone was knocking
at a door by me and then the door opens
um and i i was like and it was just
someone knocking at the door
it was just a train coming straight well
there's a level in that where a car
drives at you and you have to jump out
of the way
you freaked out it was it was pretty
scary and i'm saying that i don't
think that like you know the generation
after us are gonna find that scary
i think i think it will feel dated and
old but for now it's
it's very cool and i'm i'm doing
workouts on it
i'm doing fun games i mean what's weird
is the disconnect between how cool you
feel
while you're in the vr world and how
stupid you look
in the headset yeah that is very true
because you're like you're like in the
real world you're like oh my god i'm
like slashing these
i've got a lightsaber wow and the the
music is going with my movement like wow
you know i
am i am tom cruise really i think you've
ruined our chance of getting a
sponsorship for this because that is how
you described the game beat saber just
there
is that not a good way to describe wow
the muse slashy slashy bumpy puppy bass
i feel like i could do advertisements um
yeah but then you watch someone else
doing it and they just look like
that you remember that viral video of
the kid pretending to do lightsabers in
his basement
oh that's so old star wars kid yeah it's
what everyone looks like
he's the coolest thing that is he's so
cool
yeah okay i think we just disagree on
that okay cool well
we have a special guest and he is star
wars kids doubles man now i presume
um uh so we've vr'd we watched we
watched a film which had lots of knocks
at the door last night we watched
roman polanski's first english language
film repulsion
yes it was very good but very creepy
it's all about um a woman recovering
from child abuse i mean she doesn't
really recover spoiler
alice wins that's literally the final
revelation of the film
wow sorry guys uh although if you
watched it knowing that
it does make a lot more sense yeah it
makes a lot more sense and i also just
think it's the most interesting thing
about the film given that
roman polanski is a child abuser
it's just weird for him to just spend
all this time being like wow it must
really suck to be abused as a child
anyway off i go to abuse attract like i
don't understand
that uh how you can have both those
things and you had it once um
it was weird to me to find out that that
was made before the sharon tate murders
so for those of you that aren't familiar
with that
um roman polanski married actress sharon
tate and she was murdered by
charles manson's uh the family
um and that is depicted in another very
popular film which if i say it's
depicted in that is also a spoiler for
that film so i won't say that
um but this film is very there's
at least three instances of her being
raped
um there's a lot of murder
kind of dreamy not quite real ray yeah
it's it's all imaginable
he did roman um sorry he did uh
rosemary's baby and
we might say roman holiday roman
polanski's roman holiday would be
a horrifying version but uh yes he did
rosemary's baby and it has a similar
vibe to that in a lot of ways although i
do think rosemary's baby was better
but um so that's part of his
apartment trilogy apparently he did this
rosemary baby in a film called the
tenant and they were all horror film set
in apartments
yeah and it it it had some pretty good
jump scares
effectively you know usually films from
the 60s
the jump scares don't work so what they
had which i thought was very impressive
so
if you watch alien which really scott's
alien not james cameron's aliens the
uh i think also very good sequel the
alien kind of invented a lot of horror
cliches but if you watch alien now
because you're so used to it you know
when they turn the lighter on
and there's dart behind there's going to
be something behind her you know there's
going to be this jump you know there's
going to be this scare it's kind of
deadened it
and so it's interesting to see an old
film which still has the power to shock
and i think the biggest jump scare for
you was when it's it's the classic scare
it's the bathroom mirror scanner
closing the mirror cabinet someone
behind you yeah so like there's no one
in the mirror you open it when you close
it to someone there
but what usually happens is when they
close it
the person stays there behind them what
was extra creepy about this was
horrible the reflection in the mirror
wasn't when it was fully closed it was
when it was closing so you just got a
glimpse of the person
just for a second and that made it much
more impactful so
it was so hard and your brother pointed
out he's like i didn't realize this film
was building dread until that moment
which is maybe an hour in
yeah i have to say the first hour of the
movie is borderline boring
yeah it's mainly a pretty french woman
works in a beauty parlor
and doesn't show up for work
occasionally yeah there really nothing
happens but it it it's building up
purposefully and i think it's only an
hour and 45 minutes so it did feel a lot
longer it's like three hours for sure
um like titanic which is three hours in
the field feels just like a
dream that passes slipping through your
fingers
making you wonder whether you shouldn't
watch it again and again
tonight again now this is a shorter
episode we are watching titanic and this
is we always mention this is a shorter
episode because
uh it's it's easter and we're going to
go and um
throw eggs at teeth rats what was it
they're not rats okay i don't know if
they're stealing i think a mouse that
becomes evil turns into a rat it's not
an evil mouse she gives you money
she's a she has a very good conscience
like i have to pay for these teeth
how does the mouse understand currency
look i'm sorry i don't understand why
your
ridiculous falsehood that you tell
children the tooth fairy
a tiny person a different country that
has
a equally irrational childhood story
is suddenly completely unacceptable no
my country is the best country yeah
that's what i thought
england
[Laughter]
so we watched that movie did we do
anything else was that it
that was probably yeah neglected to play
any pranks on you for april fools which
is
although my student on the on april 2nd
my 17 year old student told me she was
pregnant and i
had a hard time with it i was just like
congratulations
i mean that's the best day today do your
april fool's pranks right because no
one's expecting
cruel to wait until the next day to do
it
um and i know it's such a classic prank
but you know what it did get me
it's a classic prank i don't think
people up and down the country are going
james i'm pregnant what no i think
that's a really classic one
really yeah i had a friend in high
school who i mean he didn't do it like
every year but yeah
he didn't do it every year he would tell
his parents that his girlfriend was
pregnant oh okay cool i was going to say
it's not really a prank if it's a boy
going
mum dad i am with childs and with a very
religious start i think we can
hit on the main story i think this week
with a
everyone's favorite old town road singer
lil naz x
oh is this his um his satanic
gay music video his satanic gay music
video yes you sold that
much much more efficiently than vr um
yes so lil nas x or lil now's
ten as the romans called him hey
released a song
to go kind of promo hand in hand with
some shoes that he was releasing
which cost 1018 and he said that's
because it's
relation to the bible verse of something
10 18.
he's like no that's just a way to charge
a lot of money for it isn't it really
well but he could have just charged a
thousand or a thousand and twenty
yeah okay so being more specific um the
these shoes by the way
were 666 pairs obviously they were an
adapted pair of nikes and nike sued the
company that made them saying well we
didn't give you permission to do this
and the air souls of the nikes had been
filled with red paint
and one drop of human blood i asked you
i was like whose blood
is being used for this so it turned out
it was members of the collective who
made the shoes
who well that sounds like a cult what do
you mean it sounds like a cult
we put our bloody shoes um
anyway nike sued them and uh they
said you have to stop making these shoes
and they said okay
we've already made them shipped them all
out and so now if you have them you can
resell them for
eight thousand dollars yeah i can
imagine yeah should have should have
bought some satan shoes
um so yeah the music video i mean you've
seen the music video yes
yeah it's lots of sort of satan um
people are very upset about it he his
argument his argument um
is that because he was like he spent all
of his youth having people like
christians put
this fear of hell and fire and brimstone
into him because he was gay
and so now he's like i'm appropriating
that this is i'm allowed to do this and
i think that's
yeah he's very good on twitter in the
he'll just clap back at people oh i used
the word clapback
yeah uh he claps back at people so there
was a
a basketball player who's like oh you
have a responsibility as a pop star who
kids look up to
because they loved old town road and now
you're giving them this this this isn't
on man and he then replied like like old
time road is about
getting high off lean and being
adulterous you're a [ __ ] parent
um which is very funny when a 19 year
old is just like
you're a [ __ ] parent well i also don't
think a 19 year old rapper does has a
responsibility
i do not think that rappers have a
responsibility i think
rap coming as literally uh
a tool to kind of speak to oppression
well and yeah and to drive change um
or just even to make the music you want
to do right i question whether i really
think any artist has a moral
responsibility
hmm yeah no i i totally agree it annoys
me when
in football or soccer as the americans
call it people say oh
it's a dirty habit all these sort of
players spit on the field when they're
playing
and it's like they're running
my like so many miles so fast they build
up
phlegm in their throats what of course
are going to spit out like this
encourages children to spit
i just remember that that scene in the
britney spears documentary when
it's like you know 2005 or something and
she's being interviewed and the
interviewer is like i mean
how do you feel about the fact that
dolly's children are now disgusting
[ __ ] because of your work
and brittany's like i don't know if i'm
responsible for
these children's sexual moralities yeah
i feel i'm a role model like whenever
people watch me i want them to
grow up wanting to be a rapper and i do
that when i do kids getting like kids
tell your parents you want to be a
freestyle rapper
i'd love to build up like a mickey mouse
club of
freestyle rappers that's a nightmare
honestly that's something right
okay kids drop a beat
i like having teeth taken by fairies
from underneath my pillow
not mice [ __ ] mice yeah that's what we'd
do
i uh i also think i immediately liked
the uh little nas
little nas little nails because
uh i just i'm just quite fond of
i just think there's a there's a long
and storied history within western
literature of portraying
satan as kind of sexy that's like not
he's not inventing that like milton does
that
yeah so that's that's paradise lost
which you you you love you love
powerless
is absolute banger by the way it is so
much fun and
uh yeah and like baudelaire does this
right he has that litany to satan poem
where he's just like satan you are the
king of you know all of us are praying
to you
i mean rock music has always been about
satan
and so it's weird that when rap is about
satan
i think i mean there is all this there's
always a moral panic when a big thing is
like
you know yeah but i also think that a
lot of rappers are quite christian maybe
more
so than actually in maybe a century or
so mainstream
artists uh mainstream like white artists
have basically being super christian
hasn't been cool
in the mainstream white media for a
while
i would say and i would agree it is
still cool to be christian
within i don't know if it's cool i think
even kanye kind of coming out and making
doing a lot of sunday service stuff is
not necessarily cool but yeah it's much
more
i think it's taken like so many rap
lyrics are referencing
george has this bit in um his essay on
kipling you make it sound like it's a
stand-up routine
george got this gross great bit he is
what babe anyway he has this bit uh
where he's like
um now he's writing this in like 1941
1942 and he says
nowadays saying you um saying you like
poetry or you
write poetry is a bit like saying you're
into god
people will kind of snicker at you and
find you a bit embarrassing
and that's from when the 40s oh wow so
this is what i mean right i don't i
don't think
i don't think in rap culture in the last
15 years
that's been true i think when a rapper
is like well you know i believe in god
no one's like okay yeah
yeah whereas if you if you believe in
god in rock then you are christian rock
when the jonas brothers had purity rings
everyone was like
well there's there is christian rap but
that's much more like
that specifically rapping about positive
uplifting things rather than
getting drunk and having sex right which
mainstream media would stereotypically
clarify
a lot of rap music has um yeah it's uh
yeah nothing no no further thoughts i
guess i just oh i guess i'm saying
people who are
complaining about little nasa's music
video i it feels
it feels weird to complain about that if
you're not also still furious about like
william blake
and charles berler like this is a very
normal thing for artists
to do yeah so tell that to south dakota
governor
christie gnome who is very christie
gnome is such a good
name it is adorable it makes me think of
a tiny little man
news story from seoul in south korea um
and this reminds me of some of our
favorite news stories from times past
and you'll know what i'm talking about
when we start
an artwork in south korea at a gallery a
graffiti wall
which uh the the art was um done in
situ by an artist and what they did was
because
the materials used to make the art or an
integral part of the art
they leave the paint and paint brushes
out in front of it like
ah this is as it was when it was created
uh a couple a man or woman in their
twenties
rocked up to the artwork and were like
oh cool we get to add to the artwork
and started painting over the artwork
until museum staff said
you're vandalizing this beautiful piece
of artwork now admittedly what they
added was just like black splodges on it
which look
[ __ ] um but i i just
like i do quite like that feeling of
like oh fun
wait oh no that makes me feel very
very stressed out because i could so
imagine thinking that that was part of
the art yeah exactly there's so many
times when you're at a gallery when you
you
you know all these modern actors yeah i
can touch this and then like the person
will go don't touch the artwork you're
like oh it's
a it's a hand print on a wall it feels
like that's what it's meant to do
the reason i mentioned it made me think
of uh the story that we we
i think think of maybe once every two
years the the old lady who tried to
restore
it makes me so sad it makes you cluey
doesn't it
have we spoken about clowiness no i
don't think we have
um all right so chloe i think it's just
such a long
i think you explained chloe pretty well
it's from um it's from
a website called wait but y that i used
to be very into uh
before he started writing all of his
articles as
eight hundred thousand word long peons
to elon musk
um but i mean don't get me wrong they're
still good
uh it's just they they take a certain
mindset whereas before
he was a little more accessible a lot of
people will know him from his ted talk
about procrastination
and that is a great joke by the way but
um so
he wrote he wrote this description of a
word he made up that i think is
really perfect called chloe and
this is the description he said uh
he said that when he was a kid his
grandfather
wanted to play clue with with him and
his sister
which for british listeners is cluedo
and
he got out he was really excited about
this and he got out all the
pieces of the game and he started
setting it all up on the table and he
tried to start explaining it to the kids
and then the neighborhood kid came in
and said
hey want to come play ball and so he and
his sister were like
sure and so they left and um
the granddad they kind of left the
granddad and when they came back you
know three hours later
the granddad had put clue away i didn't
mention it
and um tim urban who writes this you
know website was like look i know that
this was not the single saddest moment
in my grandfather's life like he fought
in wars
but when i think about my grandfather
waiting to see if we would come back to
play clue with him and then
finally just putting away the box of
clue
i feel this very like specific poignant
kind of misery
that i i have recognized in other places
that it's really hard to it to kind of
define
and he called it chloe i may have
butchered that story slightly it may
have been something that happened to his
father instead but
i think i think it's great i mean it may
have been something that happened beyond
his childhood because i don't think that
in the 1980s there were
neighborhood kids who said let's play
ball you did make it sound like it was
from the early
20th century um but i i just i think
it's such a good word because it's
it's this i get it when um when i'm at a
restaurant with my dad
and we all order dessert and all the
dessert comes and my dad
like looks over at everyone's dessert
and it's like oh my god it's going to be
really good and he's looking at all the
desserts and then his dessert comes and
his face just
falls and he's like made the wrong
desserts chose the wrong dessert
because it's something about that that
just it just utterly breaks because it's
not important but yeah so
for me my and i think that's a good the
good way to understand it is for
uh you lovely people listening to try
and figure out a moment in your life
where you couldn't figure out what the
emotion was called but you felt it so
when i learned to tie my shoelaces my
dad had sent me a challenge like hey you
need to learn to tie your shoelaces i
want to stop tying your shoelaces
and this is only three years ago um he's
like you need to learn to tie your
shoelaces
you can't keep wearing velcro forever i
had big feet and velcro shoes phase out
at a certain age
um but then if you've got bigger feet
that means they phase out at like four
or five and
i don't know when you meant to tie you
should i probably was a late developer
anyway it took me a while to learn how
to tie my shoelaces
and when i'd done it he said okay i'll
take it to the shop and you can have
whatever toy you want
and i chose a power rangers little kind
of toy set where it was like small it
folds up with the power ranger inside
and he's like are you sure you want that
you don't have any power rangers toys
i'm like yeah i want power rangers he's
like
okay you don't want to get any of these
things from the collections you haven't
no so i get it and then immediately
i'm just like ugh i don't want this and
i didn't play with it
and he was like oh you're not playing
with the toy i got you
that i think that you're right it's
chloe but what you know it's it's this
it was an eight pounds
toy it cost it's just this kind of like
inane
but poignant sadness but we feel it
about this
this woman who tried to clean up this
like ancient
mural of yes if you don't remember the
story you remember what it looked like a
woman tried to
like repaint a mural and it ended up
looking like a monkey
well it didn't even it just looked so
it's impossible to describe in words how
bad it looks and i could just imagine
this poor woman and she it became world
famous
and this poor woman just wanted to help
her clean up the jesus painting
that's all she wanted that's all she
wanted so we are our chloe hearts go out
for these people insult they weren't
charged
the police considered charging them that
seems very unfair that does seem very
unfair come on korean police time to
resurrect a long dormant segment
now it's australian news it's coming
back
it's back in australia in western
australia
perth where we visit frequently um a man
was attacked by the angriest octopus
um the news story called it uh angry
octopus
attacks perth man um he was with his son
on the beach
and they saw an octopus they thought ah
let's go have a look at that
and as they waited out to the octopus
taking his son with him because
obviously he's australian
he's like kind of oh blize fine teach
the boy about poisonous sea creatures
um the octopus just wailed on him just
properly properly slashed and slapped is
he okay
uh he's fine he had several like pretty
bad cuts from being
just whipped these octopus they're very
clever aren't they
they're super close octopode no one
knows but whenever you say
octopuses people will go octopi then
someone will go octopode
actually just say octopuses doesn't
matter what about um
no um an octopus but several
yeah yeah a herd of octopus a sea herd
um uh yeah he was just beaten by an
octopus
and you know quickly ran away well you
know man versus nature it doesn't always
work out does it it's very
very true i just i really really
australia also lose that war to the
emu's yeah the eu fought by australian
colonists so essentially the british
right
yeah and the enemies and there were
battles which
the british lost yeah yeah it's kind of
like vietnam right
for sure what it was it may not really
have been it may have been like they
were fully australian by that point
okay um essentially
armies with machine guns tried to wipe
out
herds of emu i don't know when this it
could not it
we don't know what century this was
either look i don't care i'm telling the
story as i
think it would be in a hollywood big
screen blockbuster herds of emus were
occupying
territory that the army wanted to settle
so they just
swept through these crowds of enemies
with machine guns turns out emus are
bullet sponges and just absorb them into
them making up
so much of this look i'm telling it how
it is look it up and tell me how
accurate i am i'm pretty sure i'm
nailing the emu wall
yeah for a while i had this party line
where i would ask people what their
favorite wall was and it was actually
it was very informative people had all
sorts of interesting answers
i always used to just say the war of
jenkins here which i believe you don't
know very much it's in the war of the
austrian succession someone's ear got
cut off and they started a fight right
i think you just like because of the
name yeah obviously what why can't i
like that
if i'm going for wars based on the name
it's that followed by the way that that
man in dresden who took me on a
slaughterhouse five tour
referred to the the
the war from 1938 to 1945. sorry 1939
1945
referred to it as world wide war ii
www
what's your favorite war one why what do
you mean why
why because of all the poetry is that
what is that why well the poetry is
pretty sublime it's not really a
beginner war is it
i make a part like it's not really a war
to get started like if people want to
start reading about wars what should
they start with
do not try and put people off world war
one as a literary pursuit
it is very approachable you you get
started by
reading all quiet on the western front
or watching it
uh there are two different versions you
can watch the 70s or the 1930s versions
they're both good
and have you watched both of them i
haven't but johnny my brother has johnny
and we trust we trust him when it comes
to when it comes to war films yes
one of the reasons that he didn't mind
that i was dating you was because i did
a freestyle rap for him about
the norwegian campaign yeah yeah he just
he liked that
um but anyway yeah start with that and
um there's just so much there's just so
much good literature about world war one
it is
it is i mean i know there's a lot of
good literature about world war ii as
well
but um there's
i don't know there's so much good poetry
from world war one
some people said that after the
holocaust poetry died
um i can't remember who said that
there's like a it's a famous quote
um and in my
kind of preference for poetry that rings
true i prefer poetry written before i
mean i can imagine
why that would affect it right yeah yeah
i think it it certainly for a generation
made it hard for poetry not to seem a
bit silly and spurious
yeah which is funny because in world war
one they went through some pretty awful
things but they felt like poetry was a
good way of expressing that whereas i
don't know
yeah i don't know i haven't got very
fully formed thoughts on this we're
gonna do a quick roundup of all the kind
of
serious stuff that's been going on this
week i think the main serious thing
is the uh trial of derek shervin the
police officer
who is uh accused or i mean did kill
george floyd um i'm not sure it could go
on for a long time
i mean it took them several weeks to
pick the jury um and we're kind of in
prosecuting arguments at the moment and
what's been interesting is
one of the top police officers from the
minneapolis police department testified
against derek shervin saying
there's no need to kneel on someone's
neck for nine minutes i mean
obviously anyone can testify that but
the fact that it's a very senior police
figure
gives that weight for a jury gives it
weight against um
usually the police kind of stick to
their own don't they yeah the police
will usually defend it because
it's very hard to convict a police
officer because they are protected by
qualified immunity i think is the clause
which means that whatever you do in the
line of duty you're protected
for um so yeah that's kind of like
priests
to me it really feels like the kind of
all of
the recent i mean i know it's not i know
it's been ongoing but like all the
recent attention the police have been
gaining feels to me like
the attention that the catholic priests
gained
as in in the sexual abuse scandal with
yeah yeah the church kind of protected
them moving them around
yeah other churches if you haven't seen
spotlight that was what spotlight was
about wasn't it
yes yeah i really liked spotlight it was
good for
did that win best picture i don't know
was it one of those weird ones which won
best picture i think it might
i don't think anyone keeps track of the
oscars anymore sadly
i think when green book won everyone was
like well we're done with this [ __ ]
joe biden is uh attempting to get his
infrastructure bill off the ground by
his dog
no oh no the dogs are back at the white
house okay yeah the dog that attacked a
secret service agent is back at the
white house okay well that's good to get
the
chris you gotta not drop the ball on the
importer i know because if he hasn't got
a dog in the white house he's just as
bad as trump
okay so sorry uh he's trying to pass an
infrastructure bill he's trying to press
an instructor bill which is lots of
money and
uh is you know uh some people would say
kind of being a little bit trojan horsey
in the sense that it's the
up front it's like we're going to fix
roads and build railways and
fill in potholes which are all good
things that need to be done
um america your train system is utterly
[ __ ] and what's weird is it used to be
amazing
yeah yeah you could go anywhere and now
it's like hey can i go from
la to las vegas yeah you better have a
car they're going to build a train from
la to vegas
what a smart idea what a lovely idea
like why is everyone you don't need to
drive just boom there and back
um but uh it is kind of true that there
is a lot of
uh very kind of democratic priority
stuff in there um
i cannot particularly pull out which i
can't really remember uh the things that
are not to do with infrastructure that
are getting put in there as well to try
and carry them through just as was done
with the covered relief bill because
hey if you're going to pass a bill why
not get some other good stuff done as
well
um what republicans are angry about is
that this is going to be paid for by
raising corporation tax
and how dare we make corporations pay
a bit more money they used to pay 35 got
cut down to 17 they're gonna put it back
up to 25 percent
so it really doesn't seem too if you're
making a [ __ ] ton of money
yeah you should pay some of that money i
i we are agreed on this yes i know i'm
not arguing to you i'm arguing to them
i'm shouting so that they can hear me
uh corporations um so that's that's
gonna happen i mean if it's gonna pass
it's gonna have to pass without
um any gop support because they're just
not voting for anything
at the moment because you know why why
would they
um it's all very standstill isn't it
yeah yeah
rather like most of the years of world
war one
oh please stop it um
uh not all of the years not all the
years no no
what was the most active year uh well at
the beginning and at the end of the war
there was quite a lot of movement but
then once trench warfare really began
so really the middle was a waste right
uh i would well it was
uh very tragic certainly a tragic waste
of human life
and if you want to read more might i
suggest you start with siegfried sassoon
wait isn't he aren't his autobiographies
eighty percent about horse riding yeah
and hunting
and then twenty percent horrendous war
retelling
frieza soon is uh one of my favorite
people in history and even though i know
he wouldn't like me
and i know he would be a bad guest why
wouldn't he like you
so a i don't think he really liked women
and b
he would find my interest in him uh
vaguely distasteful
i think it's good when you can have a
conversation with someone who's famous
without coming across as like a kind of
falling sycophant
yeah which is why when you met one of
the actors from game of thrones and
didn't realize they were from game of
thrones
you actually got on really well i gave
her advice about auditioning i was like
you've just got to keep at it
she was tonks from harry potter it's
just like
oh let's do a nice time chatting to that
really famous actor over there
what yeah that is tom she was so
gracious about it she was just like i
know yeah thanks yeah it's really
helpful
she probably just thought who is who are
you like are you this
taste maker like is that taylor swift
she looks different out of pictures
um but no so i would invite siegfried to
soon
to my historical dinner party who would
you have at your historical dinner party
um i would have uh you your mum your dad
and your brother and that is why my
dream meal every night is actually
attained
you're not playing the game they have to
be dead they have to be dead i don't
want to kill your family
well darling that's why you pick
someone's not in my family okay
um dream dinner party
so obviously you have jesus i feel like
that goes without saying
why because either he is the son of god
in which case
this is a good thing to know yeah or
he's not that's a good point
i just yeah but would he tell you no
because he does say he's the son of god
why can't i have god well god isn't a
historical personage
okay um
i don't know but but the thing is would
this dinner party be any more enjoyable
than just a nice night out with my pals
you're so boring it's unbelievable how
boring you are okay
i have jesus shakespeare anne boleyn
jane austen and siegfried
sassoon okay that's cool i mean that's
entirely what everyone who listens to
this podcast would predict you would
choose as well
i i used to think i wouldn't have oscar
wilde um but i've
come around on him what about hitler
stalin charlie chaplin
and we talk about mustaches and how i
can't grow one
god what a weird dinner party that would
be because they would all know but
that's the thing
so the thing i think about is like anne
boleyn
no sorry uh jane austen knows who
shakespeare is jane austen does
not want to talk to me because jane
austen is there being like oh my god
shakespeare right
shakespeare doesn't give a [ __ ] about
jane austen but stalin
hitler and charlie chaplin all know
about each other kind of
i think yeah one no hitler would have
known about the great dictator and
stalin hitler knew each other and
charlie chaplin wouldn't know
i don't think i don't know if stalin
would know charlie chaplin i don't think
stalin's there at his dacha
being like oh play modern times he was
very famous that was not a good starting
accent i do apologize
yeah uh why can't i do russian anymore
what's happened to me i feel like
what's happened to you oh yeah yeah i
can't do it this is all
i think i've had like a brain leak or
something that's gone all my russian
play modern times my name is joseph
starlin
this right you might think this isn't a
good russian accent but once i was at
the dmv and i had to call alice up and
say alice you know that russian accent
that we do
the man sitting next to me talking on
the phone has exactly the same russian
accent and i didn't ask him where he was
from because then if anyone critiques my
russian accent i can say
actually no that is a genuine blood of
stock accidents
um i don't even know who i'd seriously
have at my dinner party
think about it further and tell me later
yeah outside of the podcast yes sorry
what a cliffhanger i just don't i i
don't
engage with hypotheticals as much as i
think people want me to
no you're very unfun when it comes to
hypotheticals because you're always just
like and i don't mean in that way when
people like oh let me clarify all these
things let me keep asking my questions
like i prefer the hypothetical game
of like so my friend dougie plays a very
funny game with
would you rather have hot irons
applied to your testicles until they uh
burn
or a lovely pint of beer so you play
this game in public like when you're in
a queue
and the idea is that everyone who's
playing the game with you should just
really deliberate over it and be like oh
well is it a hot day when you have the
hot the lovely
and is the beer chilled or room
temperature because that does go a lot
and these irons how who's applying the
irons
because that does affect it and then
people just listening just being like
mate take the beer i think a final kind
of you know not very nice story is
allegations against uh congressman matt
gates
did you did you know who that was before
we've kind of i mentioned this this week
never heard of
anyone he's got he's he's got a smarmy
face
to describe him he did an interview on
tucker carlson and made tucker carlson
not the most repugnant creature on that
show
wow tucker carlson threw him under the
bus as well like matt gay so basically
matt gates has been alleged to have
transported a 17 year old girl across
state
lines which is such an american thing
which i whenever that happens i mean
just tops and tails with rowan polanski
because that's what he did right
and still can't go back to america
because like there's a warrant for his
arrest
right he was found guilty um although
rome polanski i think it was quite a bit
more severe i mean
yeah no no no i think he's but it was
like a 13 year old kid kidnapped and
raped uh yeah he was pretty [ __ ] up
anyway yes um
so uh there was transporting across
state lines of an underage girl
and he's been denied these allegations
then further allegations have come out
being like oh he's known
in the house for showing naked photos of
all the women he sleeps with
to all the other congress members it's a
weird thing to do as a politician
how reckless do you have to be yeah yeah
really um and also like you know paying
for
sex and uh like kind of being involved
with
potential trafficking through some
accountant in his state
um he went on top of carlson and kept
being saying to attack carlson like
because you know we went for dinner and
i brought a girl with me and i
i was a gentleman i paid for the meal
and paid for her cab ride and
suddenly is this a crime and tucker
carson just goes i
do not remember that didn't happen um
and at the end of it it's just like well
that was the weirdest interview i've
ever had it cleared nothing up and we're
going to keep an eye on this story
um one one thing that's interesting for
us talking about is we are from britain
right well this would be perfectly legal
yeah yeah it would be
weird the age consent in britain is 16
and chris and i were talking about this
because we had a much less visceral
reaction to this news story than like
some of my
american friends who were like oh my god
that's disgusting on our group text they
were like this is
vile and i'm there going oh um because
you know when when i was 16 i had
friends who were dating like
really old men you know yeah i mean it
is weird
but i i don't know
what i'm saying is when we move back to
the uk i can date 16 year olds so
matt if you're a fan of the podcast oh
god come over to the
but that is weird right imagine if you
were that and you were like i want to
sleep with 16 years and then you flew to
the uk for that purpose
that it's legal but it
it's really [ __ ] creepy yeah and i
talked about this and i was like what if
there was some kind of age of consent
thing where it was like a sliding scale
where like if you're
like half your age plus seven like the
rule that we have
that works perfectly seven really does
work it really does very well
um but anyway yeah and i was like so
maybe you know if you're 16 you can
sleep with like a 21 year old
and that's kind of okay but then if
they're 30 that's weird but
it gets so complicated and basically
fundamentally the issue of
drawing out a line of consent is always
going to have mistakes on either end of
it
like there's going to be people who
there's going to be people who would
have been
much happier if the age of consent had
been like 22
yeah and there's also going to be people
who would be much happier if they if the
age consent was like 15
right because people don't reach sexual
maturity at the same time
so uh yeah i don't know i think it's
really tricky i certainly think
um when you're like i remember when i
was like a teenager
i was always trying to hit on much older
dudes and luckily they were always like
oh no you're very young um this
is a trap and i remember at the time
being like age is just a number but it's
like
not and um what's
what's funny is that it often i think
feels fine for the
teenager the teenager is like i don't
see why it's a problem but then
when you hit like 21 and think about
dating a 16 year old
yeah it's a bit odd isn't it yeah
they're young
conversation that i've had with people
before is the kind of you know the
appropriateness of like
when we've met someone i've gone oh
they're cool their girlfriend was quite
young
and i've asked people because it feels
it feels weird right if you have a
friend who's like
30 something and their girlfriend is in
their early 20s
it does feel weird i think we have a
friend who says her rule is if a
if a man consistently only dates much
younger this is what i was going to talk
yeah yeah he's probably
not a very nice person yeah probably if
it's like oh all his girlfriends were 27
when he was 30 whatever like there's
nothing wrong with that and then and
then
you know and then he met a 22 year old
and fell in love that seems different
from someone who's just like uh once
they hit 23 they are
nut yeah i think fundamentally if you're
a guy who's
much older um and it's funny we keep
talking about men being older and women
being younger but
that's seems so much more common um to
me it always feels like a kind of
insecurity right like you want to be
able to show off how knowledgeable you
are
yeah what do you have beyond your life
experience and money that you can give
them right
i i just think that's what it reads like
to me it feels fairly desperate
yeah um not always like obviously there
are cases where people fall in love with
an age
gap yeah really macron his wife is like
20 years older than him
he she was his teacher you're that also
that is weird that is definitely weird
definitely a bit odd isn't it but also
they're french so you know they believe
that
mice take your teeth so i'm going to
give them a pass on that one that's
totally fine
um that's the end of all the week's news
that uh that we wanted to cover this
week i didn't tell you about how in
britain they've had to stop tourists
from getting too close to seals
not because they're like octopuses in
australia and we'll beat you
just because people will be going up
close to seals on the beach and
touching them and people like stop
touching seals
i want to touch a seal i reckon they'd
feel real nice right all that blubber
i feel like that's like a memory foam
mattress that my hand would sink into
them a little bit
yeah i wonder if they'd like it though
in uh on shackleton's
trip to the antarctic they ate a bunch
of seals they ate so many seals they're
just reading the book about it i was
like wow i
i don't want to eat any more see like as
if i felt as if i'd eaten
hundreds of seals i'm full yeah okay i'm
going to talk about another i just read
uh which was so great and i just i had
such
it was just so much fun uh and it's
called if i had your face
by francis cha and uh it was recommended
to me by a friend who recommends like
one book a year to me and they're always
bangers and
um basically it's a novel about like
korean beauty standards and like plastic
surgery and sex work and
like the oppression women face in korea
uh and what was really interesting to me
about this book so it you know it came
out
last year and it's set in seoul and
that he pronounced the soul yeah you can
say soul soul
yeah if if we get it wrong then we
apologize for being [ __ ]
uh so it's set in seoul and
what was interesting was that um it was
a lot about class
and um so the four protagonists are all
kind of like
from working-class backgrounds and um
at various points they come into contact
with upper-class men right
men who have really high-powered jobs
and
tons of money and they all seem to agree
like there seems to be this this
understanding
all the way through the book that like
the only way you can get a job
is if someone in your family is powerful
and has sway
right well i mean we've watched parasite
and parasite is you know about class and
career and
to get the job each you know the tutor
gets her dad the job driving than the
housekeeper the housekeeper job like
it's connection
yes and it was really interesting
because i mean i obviously i i have
not read a huge amount of contemporary
korean literature but it
the vibe is very like like victorian
britain
um so yeah for instance at one point
there's this
um girl who's dating an upper-class man
and all of her friends are like he's not
going to marry you
but like the book has painted the upper
class man is like really lovely and they
have a really like
it seems like a very compelling
relationship i don't want to give any
spoilers but the point is
that it um it really yeah it reminds me
a lot of like
dating above your station in like a
victorian novel
where it's like well sure he'll sleep
with her but he's not going to marry her
right like um steerforth and emily and
david copperfield
um and what a great book by the way
anyway uh so yeah it made me wonder if
that's really what it's like because
because if so um
it must be absolutely ripe for romance
novels my screenwriter
boss is always telling me that the
problem with romance um
like rom-coms right now is that because
we live in such a permissive society
there's very few reasons why two people
who are in love can't just be together
there are not the barriers that jane
austen would have right
exactly and so you have to kind of
fabricate these barriers and then
the wrong comes end up feeling really
far-fetched right and you get all these
like enemies to love those romances
where it's like
we can't be together because i hate you
yeah what women want right helen hunt
and mel gibson
they're like rivals how could they date
but obviously they can you know what i
mean
so the reasons that they can't date
usually feel very far-fetched and
um even like high school movies that
used to have that
i think in the 90s there was this kind
of clear thing of like well the jerk
can't date the loser girl with glasses
um
all she has to do is take the glasses
off and let her hair down
beautiful oh my gosh for the listeners
alice just took her glasses off and
everybody blushed she became stunningly
beautiful no
um so so i think that more modern high
school films don't have i mean
it appears and certainly this was the
case at the high school i went to that
that those kind of like
nerds and jocks boundaries are less
clear-cut than they used to be so
again you don't have that boundary that
makes romance
so tense um so i'm looking
i mean this is really stupid to say but
yeah i'm looking at what i'm seeing
from uh parasite and from if i had your
face by francis cha and i'm thinking
this is ripe for some romance right uh
which actually you get in
singapore and crazy rich asians because
she's she's um
engaged or married you know dating
seriously
this guy who's from a really really
wealthy singaporean family and
everyone's like well you can't marry her
she's not rich and it does have this
ostinian feel
i've not i've not read or seen it you
haven't seen crazy rich asians no
but it's so much fun i met people from
singapore and i told them i'd been to
malaysia because it's next to it and
they
just immediately started slagging off
malaysia people in singapore don't like
malaysia i think people in malaysia
don't like singapore but
singapore is you know essentially one
rich it's mad that singapore is
singapore's just a city right it is a
country that is a city it's like the
vatican city
like those countries blow me away i'm
like oh you're just like hey this is a
real great city
country time like imagine that i don't
know i i
always find it weird i'd love to go to
singapore i heard that conversation with
because they were like oh we've been to
the uk i went
where and they were like oh just the
airport i said what do you mean they go
just for shopping and they're flown to
the airport just to do some shopping at
the airport shops and then flowing back
god that is odd isn't it they were very
rich yeah but even so
that doesn't seem like a nice thing yeah
um i would not enjoy that
but in any case i found this book really
really interesting
and kind of it felt um
i think it's really fun when you find
like a literary book
that feels frothy at the same time and
it was it was frothy because
uh you know it was talking about like
traditionally feminine topics like
beautifying plastic surgery and
um sex work etc female friendship um
love but it you know it is a pretty
um you know upsetting book in a lot of
ways
uh and it's beautifully like really well
written and when i say beautifully
written
um it's not pretentious or like
creative writing mfa-ish even though she
did i think do a creative writing mfa
but you know how like there's a kind of
creative writing mfa book where it's
like
she ate her noodles they were soggy
like a relationship with her mother and
you're like oh god
no not entirely sure what program that
writer went to i don't think it was iowa
writer's workshop
um but it was just really good
it made me think a lot about korea and
about yeah class in korea which
is apparently like very [ __ ] up and
intriguing and old-fashioned to us
unlike our countries which have no
social problems whatsoever
but what you're saying is that you're
going to now write a korean romance
novel and we can all enjoy it when it
comes out
no absolutely not mr darcy in seoul
no but i would read mr darcy in seoul
cool well if you are an
author and you uh understand korea then
write that book and alice will read it
i will and then she'll give you her
hard-hitting opinions
because uh those of you who follow alice
on instagram will realize that she does
a bookstagram where she reviews things
how do you find reviewing books that you
don't like if it's a book that you don't
like do you review it
um i don't review all the books i read
because i find some of the reading i do
just like feels kind of
private and revelatory in a way i don't
feel comfortable with
um i also have i'm not going to be harsh
about an author who is alive
yes the author is alive and i think the
book unless i think the book is like
morally repugnant have you had any of
those um
i had one book that i thought was a
little bit racist
about um one of the rockefellers who got
eaten by cannibals on his gap year
um and the depiction of the cannibals
like i think he was well meaning but it
was a little bit exoticizing
and i i definitely wasn't i didn't like
i didn't try and spare his feelings on
that
i feel short-changed that you have yet
to tell the story of the rockefeller who
was eaten by cannibals on his gap year
um he was uh quite handsome i think it
was in the
uh 60s maybe um yeah and he was this
like rich
rockefeller who was i don't know maybe
1920
he wanted to collect anthropological
artifacts so he went to
papua new guinea um port moresby is the
capital
um i read this book a while ago so i
don't remember the details
and uh yeah basically we don't know for
sure what happened
to him but when this author of the book
went to like 30 years later went to the
same places
that the rockefeller boy had visited uh
it
he picked up what he felt were clues
that they had in fact
uh killed him and eaten him wow grim
yeah yeah not great the um
there was an italian movie called
cannibal holocaust which
is kind of very famous for being a very
gross
movie um to the extent that a court
tried the director
because they believed he had killed
actors in the making of it because he
thought it's just the scenes where
there's no way this person wasn't killed
for you to film that now
the filming is pretty disgusting because
they killed a lot of animals and and
it's
genuine animal cruelty on uh footage
in a kind of line with james bond when
they murder horses by pushing them into
the sea
from the late 60s early 70s
yeah well also it's the italian film
industry so you know
um but the director had to bring in the
actor that
the judge thought he had murdered and
was like she's alive
and this is how we made her look dead
yeah that does seem like a pretty uh
stupid case to bring to trial when you
can just bring the body the person who's
supposed to have been murdered forward
the thing was the actor had a twin
so he really got away with it um well
thank you for telling us about if i had
your
face um if i had your face yes oh my
gosh
i would be so pretty well that's very
kind of you
time for a wrap oh yes i'm just trying
to get you get on your good side for the
rap so you don't
uh try and mess me up too much alice
wynn has all the topics there on the
phone
she will throw them out at random i will
do some little rippety rapperty rhymes
about them
um this is the beat by pendo46 alice win
give me that first topic uh what's it
going to be uh
siegfried soon sig feed sassoon we like
him
he's my friend he's your friend and
everybody knows it in the war
he's a poet right in there on the paper
saying everyone will remember me later
did he die did he perish at the song no
he survived not hit by the bomb or the
machine gun you ever knew the answer you
were so expressive
and astia you were like no didn't die
sick fritz as soon as my guy come to my
dinner party like a hawk when he swoops
in but you know he never will talk to me
yes i'm gonna make you wilfred
you know what that's mistaken not even
related to the podcast that's under the
power but he died in a bomb blast yeah
got cut up with those bullets very sad
r.i.p
you should pull it from that oh what the
[ __ ] i'm shook because you rapped all
the names like rupert brooke
rupert the bow and he's in all the
forest alice no one can follow no one
knows who these guys are they were all
poets who died in the war
rupert brooke and wilfred owen when we
continue you know we are flowing julian
grenfell you can say middle finger [ __ ]
off alice i need you to bring all the
words that we did in the show
not all of these random hoes oh i let
them because they're poets i got the
knowledge and showing it all quiet on
the west
yeah oh shun move away you massive all
quiet on the western front in the 30s
they would mix it up you will hurt me i
will deserve you if you keep going oh
yes this beat is so hard to get flowing
getting more volume because it is too
low anyway get on with the show
give me more things that we rapped about
next yes here we go with the little nas
x old town road like a cowboy on a horse
all on twitter all of the talks saying
oh it's offensive to christianity he was
saying i don't give [ __ ] what ut
h i n k think translate hey making the
shoes on the floor
six or six and they don't make them more
why nike sued them they were assuming
people were getting our shelter they're
zooming
oh this ain't no fun blah
germans and france and the french took a
chance and they died and they died in
the blood in the past and they're all
like oh no
oh it's on killing people at the battle
of the somme walking
it's a whole little team whole little
squadron then the machine gun
slayed 916 all of the people the blood
was not clean on the floor it was muddy
and everyone died all of the tragic
newspapers tried
oh yeah here we go on the hip-hop when
you get octopus whip stop put it on the
back with the guard
hi australian oh now i cried i brought
my son out there in the sea i fought
fine with the sunshine for him and me
but nah
little octopus with the eight legs went
down there oh my head up got all the
wheels i've got all the welts it was so
painful i know i should have felt
brought a little bit of vinegar ammonia
when i go and piss on there and i'm
showing you oh alice i've got a little
fact
got a little baby in my back yes i'm
pregnant at 17.
oh april fools you've seen that stuff on
the day after april 2nd
everyone really have a reckoning like
we're coming with revelation
moving on now come on wait oh i need you
to talk about all the battle of eepro
oh what is she like there ibra had a lot
of snipers
there was a young lady from iphone she
got started on the cheeks
it's a limerick but i can't remember all
of the things oh car i'm going to sever
this relationship if you keep choosing
to talk about the battle of losing who
won who lost battle of blues
of the war that's the name battle
passchendaele what's in her brain all
she cares about is mentioned in the war
it's like oh can you name some battles
more she's like sure chris i know all of
them
any other things kill them much
robert graves he's probably something to
do with the poetry and war as well
and he is but alice you've you've
violated
what the wrath people wanted to hear
about matt gates people wanted to hear
about you know the george floyd trown
you were just like
no world war one so well behaved and it
is so hard for me
to ever not tell you various war related
things
to rap about so forgive me for once in a
while i
i let loose fair enough although i am
glad i don't have your face because if i
had your face then i would have the face
of a traitorous winch
uh the battle of um the battle of oprah
is the first
battle where the second battle of reap
is the first battle where um
the germans used gas an ecstasy of
fumbling
uh well that's much later wilfredon
wasn't at the war yet and
um the battle of loose is the first
battle where the british used gas in
retaliation
however the wind was not on their side
and blew the gas back at their own
soldiers
oh yeah well i'm sorry i didn't rap
about that
um i thought that was a very good wrap
it was very fast
it was too fast for you to make it that
difficult
um i love you very much and uh please
understand that the tension that you see
between us now is purely a fabrication
um it's been an absolute pleasure being
with you this week
uh it's been a pleasure with all of you
people listening if you've enjoyed it
do me a favor go give it a rating on the
apple podcast app or share it with a
friend it's
always lovely uh to have people
listening in alice they can find you on
instagram can't they yes at
let them eat books with underscores
instead of spaces and they can find
moira at um youtube and instagram chris
turner comedy or just search chris
turner
i will come up um i had one more thing i
wanted to say about the age of consent
oh yes please do
so um it was just a quick thing but i
realized i hadn't said it um
so i read this once somewhere in a book
but um i haven't
fact checked it but it was in a book
like a academic book um
so mary bloody mary um was queen of
england
and the age of consent at that time was
twelve
and her successor um queen elizabeth the
first
changed the age of consent can you
remember because i've told you this fact
before
what she changed the age of consent now
you've spelled the game
she's she changed it that's how you
spoil the game whenever people say guess
a thing
you deliberately yeah guess how much you
pay for this a dollar
no twelve dollars it ruins it it does um
but yeah
she moved it down to ten um which seems
sketchy if she was a man people would go
creep because she's the virgin queen
you're like
correct well but it's also it turns out
if you actually read into it it's not as
sketchy as it seems because the the real
issue with the age of consent in the
renaissance
was that it was simply the age um
beneath
which you needed your parents consent to
get married so
uh what this basically meant in practice
is that if you were 11
your parents could just marry you off to
someone but if you were
13 they could not you had to agree to
the marriage
so by moving the age of consent it
actually meant there were fewer child
rights
well that's good yeah well done
elizabeth i mean she didn't do it for
that reason she was just like oh
me love those 10 year old boys
[Laughter]
actually her tastes did run pretty young
oh really not like
i mean as in just like when she was an
old lady she was still dating like 20
year olds
and when you're the queen mate yes sir
matt gates if you want to keep being a
creep
you've got to get a monarchical position
um that is all we have time for this
week thank you so much for listening
it's been a delight
uh from me from alice and from the two
cats that have been very quietly
sleeping in this room during the podcast
recording
goodbye